26 year old daniel castano a third of an
inning against the nats in nationals
park on saturday first game of a
doubleheader august 22nd didn't go real
well for him
last start was september 11th against
philadelphia took the no decision the
marlins 5-3 win
gave up one run it was unearned on five
hits struck out one walk won 46 pitches
27 strikes so fastball slider changed
three pitches turned into third in soto
into scoring position at second with one
out suzuki catching the second game his
26th start as the nationals catch him
swinging a fly ball
left field moving back into his right is
dickerson he makes the catch turner tags
here comes the throw to the plate it'll
be cut off by the third baseman anderson
and the nationals have the lead here at
the top of the first inning one to
nothing soto at second with two out and
josh harrison coming up swinging a
ground ball through the open right side
basing into right rounding third is soto
is coming home he will score it's a
singular right for harrison he drops in
his tenth front of the year the
nationals get that second run home soto
in from second hits the nationals two in
the marlins nothing second start against
the miami marlins that's number five
prospect making his third career stop
start first time against the marlins it
was his debut august 22nd struck out two
and allowed four runs on six hits over
three and two thirds corey dickerson the
only left-handed batter in the lineup
for the marlins in the second game steps
in here dickerson sends one in the air
right center field this one's hit well
and it will go a home run for cory
dickerson
a spark out of the top of the lineup
it's 2-1 shot it over the wb mason sign
and the marlins pick up one of those
runs
they get one on the board it's 2-1
nationals here in the first and cory
hits a seven brian anderson over three
in the first game as this one is in the
air toward deep left center field
anderson gives it a ride anderson ties
the game
a solo home run for v.a
and this game's tied at two here in the
second home run number seven for brian
anderson his 28th run batted in second
home run for lamar
turner moves to second now with two outs
cabrera lifting one to left center
marte
edge of the track so cabrera gives it a
ride to flies out and castano pitches
around the error in a scoreless third so
coop works a walk to load the bases the
base is full for jesus aguilar here's
the pitch and he takes high ball four
crows walked in the go ahead run marlins
go up three two two down and now it's up
to miguel rojas checks her little tap
right in front of the plate mcgowan's on
it he scoops to the catcher and he
dropped the ball everybody's safe 4-2
suzuki was signaling to go to first base
mcgowan didn't think he had time
so he just underhanded the ball to the
catcher wasn't ready couldn't catch it
and martay scores to extend the lead
it's now 4-2 miami base is still loaded
here's louis brinson now this one out to
left center field it's falling fast and
it will fall in for a base hit one run
is in here comes the second making it
third in there safely and lewis brinson
has given the marlins the lead
it's now six to two so the marlins
coming up big with two outs in this
inning princess popped a shallow fly
into left field turner couldn't get back
there to reach it and soto couldn't get
in to make the play time to run in the
on deck circle as juan soto steps up and
he goes the other way and hits it
extremely hard robles scores i'll tell
you juan soto is so good at taking what
the game gives him the nationals are
within three now it's six to three and
they'll bring the tying run to the plate
and it's taken for strike three called
games out of the inning got him looking
at a slider and the national strand two
big rudders in scoring position
now two men on for brian anderson who
had a home run in the second hit a fly
ball to center in the third and anderson
hits this one a ton to left field that
is gone
second over the game for brian anderson
a three-run shot to blow it open
threw a fastball right down the middle
didn't want to walk the bases loaded so
anderson clears the bases with a
three-run shot his second of the night
his eighth of the year
it's now 9-3 miami
dickerson is blasted into right field
that's going to get down for base hit
brenson turns it third he'll come home
rodriguez heads into third base he goes
first and third hit by corey dickerson
who makes it 10-3 so corey dickerson is
three for four in this game two singles
a homer and two rvis so a position
player on the mound and with two on and
nobody out brian anderson will be the
batter and he hits a high fly ball this
is to left center it's got a chance and
it is up up and away and it's a
three-run home run and for the first
time in his career brian anderson has a
three-homer game so luis garcia to bat
this one chopped up the middle miggy
over to first a double play
and it's a marlins win the marlins get a
split 14-3 the final in the nightcap